We are on problem number 19.
If a, b, c, and f are four
non-zero numbers-- I don't
know where they got f.
I would have expected a d-- but
a, b, c, and f are four
non-zero numbers, then all of
the following proportions are
equivalent except-- OK.
So this is interesting.
This is one where you have to
work through all of them.
So choice a, a/f is
equal to b/c.
Let's see, choice b says
f/c is equal to b/a.
So the real simple way of
doing this, let's cross
multiply all of them,
essentially, right?
So we can cross multiply.
If we multiply both sides by,
essentially, fc-- and that's
what cross multiplying is-- so
we said a times c, ac is equal
to bf, right?
a times c is equal
to b times f.
And you can get there
multiplying both sides by f
and multiplying both
sides by c.
If we cross multiply on
this side, we have
af is equal to bc.
This is an f here.
ac is equal to bf.
Here we have af is
equal to bc.
Let's see, choice c is
c/a is equal to f/b.
What does this tell us?
This tells us that cb or
bc, bc is equal to af.
So these two are equal.
These two are the same
thing, right?
In d, we have a/c
is equal to b/f.
Now if we cross multiply, you
get af is equal to bc.
These are equal.
I think you see a pattern.
I suspect that e is going to
look very similar to these
three, and that this is
the different one.
But just to do it,
I'll show you.
Choice e has af/bc is equal
to 1, essentially.
So that's af is equal to
bc, which is the same
thing as all these.
So a is the one choice
that is different.
ac is equal to bf is very
different than af is
equal to bc, right?
We're multiplying different
things.
These are all the same.
Hopefully you see that.
And that's multiplication is
communicative and all that.
So it doesn't matter what
order, fa and af
are the same thing.
But here, we're multiplying.
It was saying ac
is equal to bf.
Let's do problem number 20.
And you could actually, in that
last problem, literally
try it with four different
non-zero numbers.
It actually should work out, if
you pick good numbers, if
you don't want to deal with
the abstract letters.
Problem number 20.
For all numbers x and y, let
the operation square be
defined as x square y is
equal to xy minus y.
If a and b are positive
integers, which of the
following can be equal to 0?
So a, b positive integers.
So which can be equal to 0?
So they're saying choice number
one is a square b.
And that, we learned from here,
is the same thing as a
times b, right?
It's just pattern matching,
wherever you see the
x, you put an a.
Wherever you see the
y, you put a b.
So that's ab minus y.
Sorry, ab minus b, right?
And can I come up with a
situation where this
comes out to be 0?
Well sure.
If a is 1, what happens
when a is 1?
If a is 1, then this translates
to b minus b, which
equals 0, right?
And why did I think what
happens when a is 1?
Well, this could also
be written as a
minus 1 times b, right?
If you just factored
out the b's.
So I said well, if a is 1,
then this term becomes 0.
So 1, this definitely
can be equal to 0.
It's not always 0, but it can
be, especially if a is 1.
OK, let's do choice two.
They wrote a plus b square b.
And what is that equal to?
Well, every time you saw an x,
replace it with a plus b.
Every time you see a y,
replace it with b.
So that's equal to-- that
equals-- I'll switch colors
for variety, just so you don't
get confused with this top
part-- that's equal to a plus
b times b-- times the second
term, times b-- minus the
second term, minus b.
So we can't do what we did the
previous time, because now the
term a plus b can't
equal 1, right?
There's no circumstance under
a plus b equals 1.
How?
Because they're both positive,
they're both integers, right?
So in order for this to equal 1,
one would have to be 1, and
one would have to be 0.
And neither of them
can be negative.
So this can't equal 1.
So that's not a situation in
which this is equal to 0.
So let's see if we
can solve it.
What's that equal to 0?
And of course, b can't
be equal to 0.
So we see a plus b.
We could factor it out.
We could say a plus b minus 1
times b is equal to 0, right?
We know b can't equal 0 under
any circumstances, right?
We know b can't equal 0, because
we're saying it's a
positive integer.
And so this term would have
to be equal to 0.
You could multiply this out and
you'll see where I got-- I
just factored out
just the same.
I divided each of these terms
by b and factored it out.
And then you're left with
a plus b minus 1, all
of that times b.
So if b can't equal 0, can
a plus b minus 1 equal 0?
Well a plus b minus
1 equals 0.
Then a plus b would have to
equal 1, which I said, it just
can't happen.
So under no circumstances can
choice two be equal to 0.
And now, what does
choice three say?
Choice three is a
square a plus b.
And if we map it, that's a times
a plus b minus a plus b.
And now here, once again, we can
factor out the a plus b.
So we could write this as a
minus 1 times a plus b.
And we want to see
if that equals 0,
see if this is possible.
Well for this to be equal to 0,
either this term would have
to be 0, or this term, or
both of them, really.
Can a plus b equal 0?
No, because a is positive,
b is positive,
they're both integers.
Nothing's negative.
They have to be greater than 0,
so there's no way that this
is going to be equal to 0.
But can a minus one equal 0?
Well sure, a could be 1.
If a is 1, then this expression
becomes 0.
So this one also works.
So our choices-- the
ones that could be
0-- are one and three.
And that is choice E.
I'll see you in the
next section.